hey guys pete here it's time for the
breakdown of fargo season 4 episode 6.
camp elegance sees things ramp up in the
pending gang war
in 1950s kansas city this was well
expected considering the closing moments
of the previous episode
and the fallout of that character's
death is shaping the decisions that the
canons and the fadas find themselves
having to make
overall that's a good thing it also
means that some of the most interesting
characters from season 4 are pushed to
the side this week
before i get into the recap this is your
spoiler warning
i'm going to break down everything that
happened in episode 6
so if you haven't watched it yet then
this video will not be for you
subscribe to my channel go get yourself
caught up and then come back to discuss
the big moments now let's get into it
as i just mentioned this episode
revolves around the aftermath of dr
senator's murder this means that there
isn't a lot that involves
us marshall deffy angel of death orienta
or the possibly haunted ethel rita
deffy's only scene
isn't much more than a shot to remind us
that he's still a part of the story
it's not not important he's sitting in a
car outside of otis place and he does
see
lloyd cannon and his men on their way
out but since there's no follow-up we
don't know what he makes of it
in ethereda's one scene we see her
return home for her birthday celebration
her mom has done some repair work on the
cake which was worth a chuckle and we
watch as her parents try to keep their
uneasiness under wraps
as she blows out the candles we get the
idea that the birthday girl may also be
struggling with her own uneasy feelings
as over her shoulder we get another
glimpse of mr snowman which also serves
as a reminder and it's another part of
the story that we won't be revisiting
just yet
orienta does have slightly more screen
time where we learned that etherida did
in fact send the letter to her boss dr
harvard
he receives it so he calls her in and
while this certainly hits a nerve and
worries her
she's able to use her charms to talk her
way out of any consequences
it's notable that dr harvard won't let
her see the letter she does her best to
get a look at the handwriting at least
though
and this will likely be all she needs to
figure out who the author is
after all since she let ethel rita into
her apartment she would already be on
the short list of suspects
and as viewers we know that she left her
journal behind in the closet where
orienta keeps all of her trophies that
puts the two women on a collision course
which okay
but it feels sort of disconnected from
the main story since they don't play a
big part of the episode
i'll come back to this after the recap
in the main story our dirty cop otis
finds himself in a difficult position
after returning home he's attacked in a
scene that manages to deliver
nods to the original fargo movie and no
country for old men in a single sequence
omi jumps out from behind the shower
curtain to choke him out
nearly killing him until loy steps in he
cuts the curtain just as omi releases
the choke hold allowing the man to
breathe
this in itself is a statement which
makes lloyd's follow-up monologue fall a
little flat it feels similar to josto's
monologue to canon's men
in the jail the idea behind it's fine
but the way it's all thrown together it
feels a bit
unnecessary regardless the point is made
loya's gang now
own otis which is in direct opposition
to his employment by the fadas
across town gaetano fada is spending the
afternoon listening to opera
and stabbing a dressmaker's form slash
mannequin with a large knife like you do
out the window we see zelmer and swany
arrive and since they're dressed in
lingerie the father men welcome them
inside
this turns out to be a costly mistake
and we hear violence erupt downstairs as
gaetano scrambles to defend himself from
an attack
he unloads his gun through the closed
door killing his own guy
and things don't look as if they're
going to improve for him as we watch
swanny slip through the window behind
him
zelmer makes her way up the stairs which
puts her right in his sights
so her partner has to shoot him from
behind turns out zelmer isn't happy that
she shot him
because they have orders from loy to
bring him in alive
since she shot him in the head right
above his ear it seems like that would
be out of the question
but then they realize he's still
breathing the next time we see him he's
chained to a wall with his arms tied
behind his back while he sits in a chair
and he's very much alive the shooting
the falling on the floor
the blood squirting out of his head it
all comes off as a fake out which i'm
not really ever a fan
of the one thing i can say though is at
least in this scenario they don't let it
linger
loy plans to have omi utilize some of
his boxing skills to punish the italian
just after lloyd drops another monologue
this time about sugar ray robinson the
point of it all is to let gaitana know
that murdering dr
senator is the decision that got him
killed later
there's a strangely placed flashback
where loy tells dr
senator he needs to get satchel back
doctor warns him that if he does that
it's gonna spark world war iii lloyd
then claims to have a plan
and then we snap back into the current
timeline the reason it feels so
strangely placed is because this
happened before doctor was killed but
then
also before loy made the move to
pressure otis into working for him
either way loy has otis brought in for a
meeting it's in the same place where
they're holding gaetano
so he sees him he told them where he was
and he knows they found him
he tells the cop that the kid exchange
is over and he expects him to bring him
satchel
loy plans on killing gaetano and then
taking over the town but not before he
gets his boy back
otis does have access but rightly tries
to talk his way out of it because it's
objectively a bad idea
lloyd doesn't really care how or what he
does he just needs his son out of the
fada house
otis recognizes this as a suicide kind
of mission
but he has no choice other than to go
along with it abel makes a cinematic
entrance as he returns from his new york
trip he introduces
joe bulow out of new york who he's
brought with him adding another
character from season two to make an
appearance
abel explains that new york will only
have josto's back
if he fixes the problem with loy cannon
within the next two weeks
he's about to explain the second part of
the deal when constant calamita
interrupts to inform josto that loy's
men grabbed his brother
josto asks if this means gaetano's dead
but constant doesn't actually know
abel is shocked to learn about the
killing of his counterpart dr senator
while he was gone
he's relieved to find out that josto
didn't order it but realizes the
implications and the tensions both
in-house and with the cannons
constant insists that they go after
gaitano but josto's more interested in
learning what new york's second
condition was
abel explains they said if you want to
be boss
you gotta make things right with your
brother otis
arrives at the fada house intending to
follow through with his orders from loy
but he's intercepted by constant he
tells him josto needs him at the club
immediately
so he abandons the idea of scooping up
satchel for the time
being before they get there abel
explains that the fadas are going to
have to make a trade of cash and
territory to get gaitano
back at this point it becomes clear that
josto sees an
opportunity and is putting together a
plan of his own
when otis and constant arrive he tells
the detective that he needs him to get
rid of marshall wickwear
immediately he then gives him until 2 30
to locate his brother
since they're supposed to do the trade
at 3 pm josso then openly questions
constant's loyalty
which emphasizes the fact that he could
use the man that's been helping his
brother
as a fall guy and whatever his plan is
josto then tells his brother-in-law
antoon
to go to the house tell rabbi to come
meet him
and then take satchel cannon for a drive
antoon is pretty well
unknown to us at this point other than
being the guy that fell asleep watching
his father in the hospital
his entire arc begins and ends in this
episode
he's pained as he understands his boss's
orders to mean that he wants him to kill
the child but as a loyal soldier there
isn't much he can do beyond following
them
still he tries to remind him that this
will likely result in his brother
and his son zero being killed in
retaliation this is where it comes out
that we may have been underestimating
josto's grasp on things
he doesn't seem worried about his
brother because well he hates him for
one thing
and he understands new york's position
to be that he tries to resolve things
with gaetano
emphasis on him trying rather than
actually resolving
he also thinks he can deflect things and
might even be able to talk loy out of
killing zero
by putting the blame on calamita
following the wrong brother
antoon makes it to the house where he
finds rabbi talking to his wife
he tells rabbi the boss needs to see him
alone he does as he's told
telling satchel goodbye with no idea
what's about to happen
antoon has a moment with his family and
tells the cannonboy to grab his coat
because they're going for a ride
his wife puts together the pieces of
what's happening and she starts to pray
he tells her not to wait up for him as
he leaves
rabbi meets josto outside joplins the
boss instruct him to go see abel but
rabbi's concerned about satchel
when asked josto just says the kid's
gone
and then he drives off that sends rabbi
back to the house where he shoots one of
the fodder men
and demands information from antoon's
wife
he's taken satchel to a remote location
he walks them through the woods and the
ruins of an old building
antoon explains it's where he was
brought after he was captured in the war
he was almost dead cooking his belt when
the americans found and saved him
he recalls seeing fields of corn and
remembers the smell of the bread
bringing him back to life in the land of
plenty he remembers the big american son
and how it made him grow big and strong
he tells the boy how he carved his name
on a stone
antoon dumini american and tells satchel
to climb down and get a look at the
carving for himself
as he does the man tries to follow
through with his orders
we see his hand trembling as he holds
the gun out
ready to fire trying to fire he tries to
force himself to pull the trigger while
hearing his own children's voices in his
head
ultimately he can't go through with it
and places his gun back in his jacket
but just as he does that a single shot
rips through his back
killing him rabbi had shown up just in
time
and tells the boy that the war is on and
they're not safe
sacha wants him to take him home but
it's not safe there
either the boy confesses he's scared and
rabbi responds me too
in the car he explains i never got to
choose
a child soldier that's what they made me
but that's not going to happen to you
understand satchel understands and rabbi
explains they're going to figure out a
quiet place to ride out the war
if he wants to go home after that he'll
take him there he wants them to be able
to choose for himself
the episode ends back at the hospital
with a brief check-in with orienta we
hear her patients groaning stop
as she exits his room when she hears
that it's stopped we see a smile stretch
across her face
it appears that the letter wasn't enough
to stop her from taking another victim
so it's a mixed bag of an episode i
think overall it flowed slightly better
than the previous one and the big set
piece with satchel was more engrossing
than dr
senator's ending i could do with less
monologuing and definitely didn't need
the fake out killing of gaetano
things are still feeling a little messy
but it was very nice to see the payoff
with rabbi making his move to save the
hostage
i think that was definitely the heart of
the episode even though antoon was
nearly a brand new addition
into the mix i think the whole thing
still worked the actor did a great job
and the backstory
coupled with the impossible situation he
now finds himself in
made it matter when he died especially
after he couldn't go through with the
killing
rabbi doing what makes sense for what we
know of him gives me hope for where
things are going
i mentioned coming back to ethel rita
and orienta
and how they both feel outside the main
story at this point i guess it's natural
in a situation where you have so many
characters to follow
but that doesn't make it any more
enjoyable ethel rita was introduced in a
way that made her feel
central to everything orienta came on
strong to feel like a super interesting
wild card
now you have these two compelling
characters in many ways more compelling
than the leaders of the two crime
families
and it's hard to see how they'll fit
into the big picture
josto putting together a plan that is
pretty devious
and also might work adds some depth to
the character
i'm just not sure how believable it is
based on his nearly cartoonish
introduction
this felt like we're moving in the right
direction at least and it's good to have
abel back in the picture
especially now that dr senator's gone
another thing that stood out here for me
was that there were a lot of great shots
in this episode where some of the
episodes structuring
and over reliance on monologues isn't
exactly to my liking
this is still a great looking show with
great characters
and great cinematography i particularly
like the sequences at gaetanos and
otis's places
some of my favorite shots in those were
swanny and white appearing in the window
and the bullet holes in the door which
reminded me of blood simple
as far as other coen brothers references
i mentioned the shower curtain choking
out scene
and then antoon taking satchel to the
woods definitely made me think of
miller's crossing
it was also pretty cool to see joe bulow
make an appearance
and it does make you wonder how things
are going to play out in kansas city
how this will all connect to the joe
bulow we meet a couple decades
later he worked his way up in kc mike
milligan was one of his underlings
it's all pretty interesting so i'm gonna
leave it there
i'm still on the same place i was last
week there's a lot of great stuff going
on
but it still has that feeling that the
whole isn't as great as the sum of its
parts at this point
but we're moving we're getting some
payoff and i still have hope that
they'll bring it all together in a way
that will be
satisfying at the end so let me know
what you think
leave a comment and tell me where you're
at please like this video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon